and our subject behold the man behold the man
john 19 reading from verse 4. it's good to see you
god bless you let me thank god again for the high
honor of being here to minister the word to you
it really is an honor and i thank him for
it and my desire right now is to lift up
christ as effectively as i can because
he himself said and he cannot lie and i
if i be lifted up from the earth you finish
it for all men unto me of all religions
of all cultures of all colors of all economic
backgrounds and if that's not being done
then the problem is we're not lifting up jesus
are you following my reasoning christ
said if you lift me up i will draw all
not just blacks black white blue green pole cannot
pin stripe i will draw all because the gospel
is for all sin is not a cultural expression sin is
a human expression are you with me and the cure is
christ if you're buddhist your problem is sin the
solution is christ if you're rich your problem is
sin the solution is christ if you're female or
male your problem is sin the solution is christ
if you're educated or not your problem is sin the
solution is christ when we strip down the gospels
to its essentials we are not nearly as intimidated
as we tend to be by the prospect of going to
this group or that group or that culture i was
talking to i think it was my wife or somebody
and i said in every culture people understand
what a smile means in every culture you smile
you get a favorable response in every culture
if you show respect you get respect back
in every culture a hungry person wants food
in every culture a thirsty person wants water
in every culture someone in a
burning house wants to be rescued
otherwise trips it down to the bare bones and
even beyond that when she wrote there are only
two classes in the world today and only two
classes will be recognized in the judgment
those who violate god's law and those who obey
but long before she wrote the holy ghost told us
then peter opened his mouth and said of a
truth i perceive that god is no respecter
of persons but in every nation the greek word
ethnos meaning ethnicity he that feareth god
and worketh righteousness is accepted with
him let me say it again differently if we
would view humanity the way god does a
lot of the suffering we would not have
i don't need to preach two sermons but this
is on my mind the fact that adam's sin did not
mean the world should be as miserable as it is
today yes christ still had to come and die but
the world could have been a much more pleasant
place than it is now had we done certain things
adjusted our thinking to think like god god says
there are two groups obey disobey do what's right
or not those are the two groups he didn't
say white black blue green asian tall short
two obey me disobey if we
follow that divine sociology
all the tribal warfare all the class warfare
all the ethnic cleansing all of that
satanic rubbish would not blight the world
and so we have to see things through god's
eyes not ours through god's eyes who was it uh
brother kerr is brother kerr spoke this morning
told us how god sees every person a christ saw
every man every woman as a potential candidate
for the kingdom that was it a potential i was
talking to a in zimbabwe a business person
who came to my hotel room to talk with me and
i told him and his partner when someone walks
into your business do not see a customer first
see a child a potential child of the
kingdom of god the customer side will
take care of itself are you with me do not see
a customer first because if you see a customer
right next to the customer will be a dollar
sign or euro sign whatever sign australia uses
see a potential member of the kingdom of god you
see that first and let god take care of the rest
anyway do three little favors for me favor number
one please open this and turn off your phones
several years ago i was preaching in australia
i don't recall what city brisbane melbourne or
uh what's the other one sydney right here and you
know outside of australia we think australia has
three cities brisbane melbourne and sydney and
that's it nobody ever mentions perth on the other
side of the universe but uh i was in some city
preaching and the lady sat we were in a theater
you know sloping seats the pit where the band
plays and her phone rang and she reached into her
handbag took out the phone answered it conducted
a conversation right under my nose and then when
she finished she put it away and continued
looking at me as though she'd never sinned
so i uh is the most extreme experience i've ever
had with a phone in the presence of a holy god do
you know if you go to a courtroom well in my part
of the world you can't take the phone in there
here as well if you're a man well let me
not say that because there's a man that i
don't say all right you can't drink water
in a courtroom drink it before you come in
you will not die if you don't drink during
the trial just drink it before you come in
the courtroom is not a restaurant you can't
massage your wife's neck play with her hair you
can't do that are you with me but we do it in the
presence of god all the time i see it with these
and so when i ask you please turn your phone
off and speaking from god's perspective
god loves reverence you know god has
killed people before for lack of reverence
and he hasn't forgotten how so please
turn your phones off if you can
all right favor number two pray for me while i
speak and simply say lord put your words in that
man's mouth i think of the words of david
in second samuel 23 verse 2 where he said
the spirit of the lord spake by me and his word
was in my tongue very precise i only want to speak
god's words if you pray god will answer and you'll
be safe because what i say will be god's words
your mind will be safe because once i say what i
say and it enters your head you can't get it out
let me say it again as you listen to me and what
i say is entering your mind you cannot get it
out and so if you pray what enters your mind
will be the words of god and there's no need
to get those out and favor number three think
as you listen think i've often said and we'll
always say if people would think they would
not do the things they do they wouldn't smoke
if you stopped and really fought what smoking
does to the system people wouldn't drink
they wouldn't date the people they date
if they would stop and think what am i doing
are you with me let us think as we listen
to god's word let's borrow heads and pray father
in heaven thank you for the gift of life we thank
you so much for acts 17 28 in him we live and move
and have our being we acknowledge you today god as
the source of life and the sustainer and preserver
of life and as we prepare to listen to your word
we ask you first day god remove the static that
interferes with our grasp of signals from heaven
and that static is sin forgive us father grant to
us the spirit of truth jesus said in john 16 13
how be it when he the spirit of truth is come
he will guide you into all truth dear god
instruct your spirit to guide us into truth
or we will surely guide ourselves into error
now father let the angels surround this place
protect us as we worship you be not only with
me but whoever else is making a presentation now
bless that person i pray in jesus name let god's
people say amen and amen our subject behold the
man behold the man john 19 reading from verse 4.
we read from the king james version of
the bible john 19 reading from verse 4
and if i don't wait for you to find the books
bear with me because time flies very quickly
then pilate therefore went forth again and
saith unto them behold i bring him forth to
you that he may know that i find no fault in him
verse 5 then came jesus forth wearing what the
crown of thorns and the purple robe and pilate
said unto them what behold the man here he is
here is your jesus here he is pilate presents
jesus to the jews behold the man take a look
at him i find no fault in him now you and i are
looking at the same man i find no fault you seem
to find every fault here he is take a look at him
behold the man but my emphasis today is behold god
now why do i say that for most of my life and
i grew up in a christian home very godly mother
she still is 97 lives in berrien springs campus
of andrews university and prayed all her life
she's lived all her life for her children
and she still does that today at 97. and
so from my childhood up i always see the
bible as old and new god the father in the old
jesus in the new that's how i have seen the bible
until much much later in my more advanced years
and i had time to reflect without the interference
of other somebody else's opinions or philosophies
that i realized and of course considerable insight
from the writers of ellen white and i thank god
for that woman's ministry and the other pioneers
i really do sometimes i just thank god and i go
down the list thank you for ellen white thank
you for james white thank you for jana andrews
thank you for whomever just thank you for these
people and of course the modern writers who love
the bible and respect ella white's office and
i realized based on scripture and the writing
from the prophet that it is not god the father
in the old testament and the son in the new it
is jesus from genesis of revelation are you with
me and if that being the case everything we do
every subject we study every ministry we promote
or seek to develop should be done in the light of
the son of righteousness jesus christ in order
for it to have its proper meaning and to take
its proper place in our lives everything must
be done from the perspective of jesus christ
nobody said amen amen hallelujah
all right the blessing is upon you
now let us go to genesis 1. genesis 1
but before we read that let's read two verses
prior to that hebrews 1 1-3 our subject behold the
man hebrews 1 1-3 when you found it say amen who
knows all 66 books in order can i see your hand
you know them in order you can just recite
them in order we have one anybody else
two three you didn't raise your hand with much
confidence are you sure all right you're not sure
you give no we don't want to give it
a go we want you to do it or anybody
else the books of the bible from genesis
to revelation without missing a book who
all right you're all modest you don't like
to show off i understand all right let's go
to hebrews 1 reading from verse one i don't mind
if you read with me we need more group readings
of god's word read with me god who at sundry
times and in diverse manners speak in time past
unto the fathers by the prophets hath in these
last days spoken unto us by his son carefully
now whom he hath appointed heir of all things
by whom also he made the worlds stop by whom
also he who is he the father made the world who
is whom jesus christ by in other words the father
instructed christ to carry out the father's
wishes which was the creation of the world
and christ did it at the request of the father by
whom he made the worlds now let's go to ephesians
1 and have that teaching backed up ephesians
not one for ephesians 3 reading from verse
9. reading from verse 9 read with me what
does this say and to make all men see
what is the fellowship of the mystery which from
the beginning of the world has been hidden in god
who created all things how by jesus christ okay
so here again we have you know the bible says
in the mouth of two or three witnesses shall every
word be established so we've just established and
we can find other biblical witnesses that christ
created yes but at the request of the father
but the one who created was christ let's
go to john 1 our subject behold the man
our overall theme what is our theme knowing
the time john 1 we read from verse 1
when you're there say amen the bible says read
with me in the beginning was the word and the word
was with god and the word was god stop let's think
now when you conduct your bible studies read the
verse you intend to study many times a minimum of
10 times each time you read it read it as if it is
the first time you're reading it and when you read
listen to the words now read out loud by the way
if it doesn't disturb anybody else read out loud
when you're memorizing also memorize out loud
you listen to the words as you're listening
to the voice of god literally in the beginning
was the word and the word was with god and the
word was god how many persons do we have in verse
1 2 name them the word and the word god and the
word we have two the verse says in the beginning
was the word and the word was with god and the
word was god now since they're two two can be one
numerically two is two one is one but two can be
won qualitatively what do i mean by that in spirit
in character in nature in heart in ambition they
are one word and god the word was god equal with
the father first two the same was in the beginning
with god how many do we have two name them
no god are the same yes but the same means
the word but i want you to be precise all
right look at verse three now you read
it for me all things by and without him
now listen to that again
all things were made by them
but how many did we see two but when
creation is described how many are mentioned
one all things were made not by them but by him
and without come on verse 3 and without him was
not anything made that was made which makes christ
absolutely what without him was not anything made
that was made that makes christ absolutely
in this principle christ is indispensable
so when the bible says in him we live and move
and have our being to whom is it referring to
specifically the creator jesus christ now having
said that keep this in mind remember john 1 1
in the beginning was the word the word was with
god the word was god our subject behold the man
now go to genesis 1 as i originally said
genesis 1 we'll read from verse 1 to verse 3
a 1 to 5. read with me in the beginning god
created the heaven and the earth stop does that
sound similar to in the beginning was the word and
the word was with god and the word was god there's
a similarity you go to first john 1 1 that which
was from the beginning which we have heard which
we've seen with our eyes which we've looked
upon our hands have handled the word of life
same person in the beginning god created the
heaven and the earth and the earth was without
form and void and darkness was upon the face
of the deep and the spirit of god moved upon
the face of the waters and god said what let
there be light and there was light and god
saw the light that it was good and god divided the
light from the darkness and god called the light
day and the darkness he called night finish the
verse and the evening and the morning of verse 5
were the first day now who said let there be light
well i can't i can't de-merit
you for that but i jesus christ
he's god yes they're all god
with respect to their divinity
but they do different things are you following
me now they can all do the same thing
but they do different things they have
different administrative responsibilities
but in essence and substance they're the same
now it was christ who said let there be light
it was christ who said let there be a firmament
in the midst of the waters verse 6 verse 9
let the waters under the heavens
be gathered together unto one place
whatever you see let there be in genesis 1
it is jesus christ speaking the creative word
then the bible introduces us to whom
christ so as verily as pilate said what
behold the man the bible says what at this
very beginning behold the god behold god
behold the creator who will one day become the
savior we are introduced in chapter one to christ
the first chapter of any book is indispensable
to understand the rest of that book
am i speaking in left field oh left field
means nothing to you am i way off am i way off
listen again the first chapter or the
introductory part of a book is essential
in order to understand the rest of the
book the bible introduces us to christ
let there be light that was christ now listen
to second corinthians chapter four verse six
i actually go there then we listen read second
corinthians 4 6 our subject behold the man
now why am i making this
presentation i hinted at it earlier
we must do nothing unless it is
connected to the cause of christ
thank you again sister i can only assume perhaps
you're thinking or you're sleeping with your eyes
open i'm not sure which it is but i'll let
you know when i determine which one it is
all right second corinthians 4 6. do you
have that read with me for god who commanded
the light to shine out of darkness stop read
that and give me the uh the australian version
uh well that's correct but that's not
the version i want but you're correct
based on what we've said about jesus give me the
what's this place called bethshan bethshan version
for god who commanded the light to shine out
of the darkness say that differently for christ
who commanded the light to shine out of darkness
go on have shined where in our hearts come on to
give the light of the knowledge of the glory
of god in the face of which is his own face
so we are introduced in the bible to
jesus christ and we subsequently discover
that jesus christ introduces us to somebody else
who is that the father now why
was that necessary go to isaiah 59
isaiah what's the nickname for isaiah
the gospel prophet what's the nickname
for jeremiah all right okay fine isaiah 59
let's read verse 1 verse 2. isaiah 59 1-2 read
with me this side read for me my left side
your right what does it say behold the lord's
hand is not that it cannot uh neither his ear
that he cannot now listen carefully to verse
two go on your iniquity is gone have separated
her between you and your god keep reading and
your sins have hid his face from you that he
okay now keep this in mind your sins have
separated between you and your god your iniquities
and your sins have hit his face from you let's
go to acts 20. read something interesting
read verse 20 and 21 of the book of acts acts
20 20 and 21 the bible is very precise book
salvation is a scientific process when
you think of science you must be precise
what book did i say what chapter what verses
this is paul giving his final address to the
elders at ephesus he's about to leave them they
cry on his shoulder at the end of that chapter
he'll never see them again so these
are the last words of a dying man
are you acts 20 verse 20 read with me and how i
kept back nothing that was profitable unto you
but have showed you and i've taught
you publicly and from house to house
testifying both to the jews and also
to the greeks now read carefully go on
uh-huh
now okay let's read that again
testifying both to the jews and
also to the greeks what did he testify
and say repentance towards god stop
we repent to god why
it's his law we break
now finish the verse repentance towards god but
for that repentance to be accepted it must be
on the basis of what finish the verse and faith
in what in our lord jesus christ is sacrifice
now this is very precise we say sorry to god
on the basis of the sacrifice of jesus christ
i pause briefly for that to sink in
brother you can say it again i will i will
repent and make several statements about
this very thing repentance towards god
now read revelation 13 8 without going there
and all that dwell upon the earth shall worship
him whose names are not written in
the book of life of the lamb finish it
slain come on now listen carefully
to me i'm not trying to create any
headaches for anyone what do you understand by
the lamb slain from the foundation of the world
say that again all right played and
organized planned and organized uh-huh
but slain from the foundation of the world
say that again the passover lamb
all right sister you're correct
okay represent symbolized by the
animal that was slain but we're
not gods through the animal adam did before
sin there was a sacrifice provided uh-huh
he knew the end okay all that is correct well
let me ask you this well you're not on the
wrong track you're in the right direction
yes you're in the right direction but
maybe the wrong road okay how was
abraham saved tell me quickly in what
in a redeemer all right what's a redeemer samantha
who does what dies redeems or buys back what's the
price of that buying back his blood his sacrifice
now the bible says christ is the lamb slain from
when the foundation of the world in other words
the effectiveness of christ's blood was the reason
why abraham muslim was saved are you following
me there are not two ways to save anybody
there's one the blood of christ abraham
was saved by the blood of christ amen
i believe elohim writes in bible commentary
volume 1 page 10 84 paragraph 8 that the
blood of christ was just as effective to save
abraham as when he shed it on calvary's cross
now let me take your mind one inch deeper
can god die no can humanity die all right if the
blood was slain from the foundation of the world
then the humanity of christ was effective
from the foundation of the world
okay i lost you you don't look lost but
you're lost listen to me again well let's pray
father in heaven i'm just trying
to give what you've given me
help me to do it very very clearly so no
mind goes astray in jesus name i pray amen
first timothy 6 16 says who alone hath immortality
immortality means you don't die if the blood of
christ was effective from the foundation of the
world and divinity cannot die so divinity does not
shed blood are you following me then the humanity
of christ must have been just as effective from
the foundation of the world in order for his blood
to be effective from the foundation of the world
are you with me because you cannot separate
the blood of christ from his humanity one
of the reasons he became human was that he
might taste what death come on for every man
so if his blood was effective
from the foundation of the world
his humanity was effective from
the foundation of the world
here we are introduced to
the bible the word of god
we have offended god and the only way back to this
god is through whom jesus christ don't hesitate
it's through christ and so we are introduced in
the very first chapter of the bible to the only
way we can return to god and that is how through
jesus christ so as verily as pilate said behold
the man genesis 1 1 says behold the man who is
god now behold god who will one day be man we
are presented with jesus christ now listen
to christ himself let's go to john 5
as we continue behold the man a quarter to 12.
john 5 christ is a beautiful chapter by the way
at just a beautiful chapter and i hope you'll find
it within your busy schedules to read it several
times slowly prayerfully meditate day their night
upon it we read from verse 45 of john 5 when you
finally say amen read with me do not think that
i will accuse you to the father there's another
that accuses you who's that even moses in whom
he trusts for had he done what believed moses
you would have what believe me for he wrote
of me now stop tell me the books moses wrote
most genesis actually okay the first five genesis
being the first one jesus said moses wrote of me
he wrote of me now listen to christ
again in luke 24 verse 44 i believe it is
luke 24 reading verse 44 are you there
all right begin reading what does jesus
say and he said unto them these are
the words which i while i was yet
go on all things must be fulfilled which were
in the and the prophets and the psalm concerning
me now he gives the whole spectrum of the old
testament the law of moses first five the prophets
the psalms now in verse 27 of the same chapter
let's go there you know it very well and
beginning at moses come on and all the prophets
he expounded into them and all the scriptures
the things concerning himself why because if you
work back you say jesus is in all the scriptures
and we're so familiar with john 5 39 what
is that saying search the scriptures come on
for in them you think you have eternal life
come on and there are they which testify of me
let me say it again as we continue the final
section of behold the man the bible introduces us
to the mediator between god and
man in the very first chapter
the very first words spoken in the
bible as recorded were spoken by christ
let there be light now let me give you a witness
to that that no one can refute go to hebrews 1.
you know noah you know all the arguments about
divinity are usually around jesus christ not
the father are you following me people don't
argue about the father he's divine he's what
he's everything it is always about christ the
argument swirl and the controversies very few
arguments swirl around the legitimacy of the old
testament it is all about the new testament that
people have these arguments whether the books are
reliable or not the old testament is virtually
free i said virtually free from controversy all
right listen to god the father now as he weighs in
on christ hebrews 1 let's read from verse 7
first we can all read together hebrews 1 verse 7
when you found it say amen read with me and of
the angels he saith who maketh his spirits and
his ministers are flame of fire verse 8 but under
the sun he saith thy throne o god is forever and
ever a scepter of righteousness is the scepter of
thy kingdom verse 9 thou has love righteousness
and hated iniquity therefore god even thy god hath
anointed with the oil of gladness above thy fellow
stop now take a deep breath now who's speaking
the father about whom the son now listen to what
the father says about the son in verse 10. come
on read and thou lord in the beginning come on
has laid the foundations of the earth go on
and the heavens are the work of our hands
whom does the father identify
as the creator jesus christ
then who said let there be light jesus christ
but at the request of whom the and father
in chapter 1 we have presented to us
this is the one through whom
you and i can approach god
jesus it's the same thing in exodus leviticus
numbers come on say the books deuteronomy come
on joshua judges ruth first samuel ii samuel
first kings second kings first chronicles
second chronicles ezra nehemiah esther job
psalms proverbs ecclesiastes songs of solomon
isaiah jeremiah lamentations danny ezekiel
daniel hosea joel amos obadiah jonah
micah neham habakkuk zephaniah hagara zechariah
malachi come on matthew mark luke john acts
romans first corinthians 2 corinthians galatians
ephesians philippians colossians 1st thessalonians
2nd thessalonians come on titus 1st timothy 2nd
timothy titus philemon hebrews james first peter
second peter first john 2 john third dawn jude
revelation and who's the superstar jesus christ
if we do not adopt that approach we
will miss deep truths from god's word
christ is the center of the bible he is introduced
in genesis 1 and spoken of in revelation 22 21
surely i come quickly even so come lord jesus
and so today i simply want you to rethink the way
you read the bible even if you read all
the begats read them in the light of jesus
when i say jesus the man and his righteousness
are you with me christ's righteousness is
the backbone of the bible whether you say
jesus or christ and his righteousness
that is the spinal column of the bible
you know every book has a spine you know
that the spine of the bible is jesus christ
as you read your word of god
the word of god look for jesus
i only recently realized that the
superstar of revelation is not the beast
but if you listen to the way we present prophecy
the beast gets more attention than jesus
now you may disagree that's my
observation the beast gets more tension
than jesus the king of the north
gets more attention than jesus
but the central figure of revelation is christ
and of course his eventual victory over satan
and all the agencies through satan works
to frustrate the word of god jesus christ
is the central figure of revelation and
his companion book which is called daniel
now the bible says in second corinthians
3 verse 3 let's go there i'll close
just want to make a comparison
second corinthians 3 verse 3 we just said
christ is the central figure of the bible
now i'll read second corinthians
3 verse 3 what does this say
for as much as you are manifestly declared
to be stop paul calls us an epistle
if we are an epistle are you with me what should
be the central figure in this epistle of my life
jesus christ who's the central figure in this
our real epistle who should be the central figure
how many will say lord help me in all i do
to make christ the scent of my life can i
see your right hand do you mean that come on be
honest with me do you mean that stand up with me
the central figure and the reason why we
do whatever we do and i really mean that
and that applies to any age whether you're 17
or 117 christ must be the center of the life
doctrines are merely designed to explain christ
but a person who is god and man at the same time
he must be the center of our lives you know we're
well known for our health ministry but i sometimes
wonder if we do disservice by just presenting
eight laws of health all of which are fine
but i wish adventists would say the number
one law of health is confess your sins
amen confess your sins yes drink water you know
stay out in the sun as long as you like you know
get fresh air whatever else their laws but confess
get right with jesus are you with me eloise writes
the consciousness of right doing is the
best medicine for disease bodies and minds
the consciousness of right doing and
right doing simply means living out
the righteousness of christ heads bowed eyes
closed father in heaven we thank you for jesus
uh what a sweet savior he is a god who's also
man and in this lord almost unexplainable state
he understands our problems and as god he can do
something about it he understands the way we think
as man he understands the way you think as god
and in him he puts my hand in your hand the father
and unites us we thank you for jesus
dear god it is by your will that he
created heaven and earth it is by your will
that he is the central figure of the bible
help us the god to re-define or to rearrange
our thinking so that christ is first and always
in all that we do and all that we think bless us
now as we continue this camp meeting let christ
be seen clearly because as clearly as he's seen so
clearly will we reveal his character because your
word says by beholding we become changed bless us
we pray bless the food we're about to eat the god
merit nourish us so that we may understand
spiritual things bless those who provided it
we ask in jesus name let god's people say amen
and amen god bless you enjoy the rest of the day
you